yes after hitting the coachella stage
for a history making performance bb
joins us now what's up girl welcome to
e.t thank you so much for having me you
were part of 88 rising head in the
clouds forever set at the festival how
did it feel up there um it was quite
overwhelming yeah it was like it was
like my first time to be nervous were
you nervous actually yeah it was so it's
[Applause]
yeah
did it feel like did you feel the energy
from the crowd and all that love because
they were going crazy when you came up
yeah they were all crazy and they all
sing along you know i've been going to
coachella for so many years and you're
right it has turned into this huge
spectacle but i've never been backstage
what was it like back there who did you
meet it hate rising stars are all there
and there was rich brian there was
warren hugh there was jackson yep yeah
and freaking 21. come on
they reunited yeah and my favorite melee
okay yeah so
we were like cheering each other and
like yeah we can do it
yeah like family like asian avengers
like
yeah
because it was the first time a record
label got a performance slot at the
festival where they can highlight all of
these amazing artists
yeah it's it's like really historical
not only did you perform at coachella
but you also debuted your new single
right best lover um what did it what was
it like to finally like share that with
the rest of the world because i love
that song yeah it's sexy
guys you have to listen to it um
i mean guys it's really good
it is yeah it is so uh i want everybody
to love their self yeah so love their
own best lover so i i wanted to share so
much and everybody loved it so i'm so
happy is it nerve-wracking debuting a
new song on a stage like that yeah it
was my first time yeah yeah but it was
worth it right now you're like everyone
download it go get it
watch the music video exactly yeah it
was really expensive
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you look so beautiful in there how
much fun was it to put that visual
together visually i had so much fun with
it and um all the you know story lines
and director and i
co-co-directed yep yeah we made each
other yeah so yeah it's quite dope it
was amazing it was amazing all right we
want to get to know you a little bit
more bb my first question is where did
your stage name come from
um
my full name is naked bibi so
and basically
it was naked baby
so you know all babies
are born naked you're born naked so i
want to be i wanted to be like really
honest and i really wanted to
um
uh
like honestly
make honest lyrics and music that's why
i choose that name and be your authentic
self yeah your true self yeah and and
love her too you know you know get naked
baby hey
okay would you say you're a lover and
not a fighter yeah i'm not alone i'm in
love with that okay all right um so tell
me about your early years as a musician
i did you always know that you wanted to
pursue music actually i started writing
lyrics actually a poem okay yeah because
i wanted to you know be cool
all the 13 years old like that so i
wanted to be cool and i was writing a
poem and like i listened to hip-hop and
all of a sudden all of a sudden i wanted
to be a rapper but my rep skill was not
good it was like
not good so i was like maybe i should be
a singer okay yeah an r b singer it
really you know k-pop and r b always go
together it's the right vibe for you
isn't it yeah yeah um i wanna talk about
the the moles that you drew on your eyes
what do they signify and i also read
that you wanted to get them permanently
tattooed is that right yeah i i tried it
to have tattoo of this but my bosses was
like my bosses was like you are going to
act
so don't do that right and i
i guessed it
obviously and um this means a lot to me
my grandpa had this tumor before before
he passed away
yeah so i wanted to be like smart and
you know
uh loving
beloved people person like my grandpa so
that's why i started uh draw on two dots
so a nice little tribute to your grandpa
too yeah i love it you know you've been
called a disrupter in your genre you
know and
because you defy genre i feel like
you're not just one thing how would you
describe your sound in your music um
i don't know um
three word okay cute sad and weird cute
sad and weird yeah i love that you know
you are cool too i'm gonna throw a
fourth one in there you're all so cool
you know oh i think that i think the
weirdos are the funnest ones yeah yeah
that's right yeah weirdos change the
world they change people okay i love it
who are your musical influences though
um
actually i
get my musical influences
from movies a lot you know uh poongjun
ho parasite director pong juno and
quentin tarantino hey
okay
yes you need to be in a quentin
tarantino movie yeah
don't you think you'll be watching
where's kill bill three clinton and
let's get her on there
against uma thurman
right yeah uh well by the way i love
your uh your single the weeknd two which
you also performed at coachella
[Music]
i mean between these hit singles and
performing at this major festival what
else can we expect in 2022 2022 i'm uh
i'm making my full-length album okay my
first full-length album so and there
will be stories there will be webtoon
and there will be
a lot of
films so i wish you guys yeah okay
anyone you have a anyone you're dreaming
of collaborating with on that debut
album oh my god i don't know um rosalia
yes who's going on tour this year yeah
oh my god i'm so excited i know
rosalia and kendrick lamar big
fan of him yes yeah kendrick lamar i
hope that happens yeah um and i hope
quentin tarantino cast you in his next
movie okay i think you got the star
quality for your last last movie
exactly well congratulations on
everything and i can't wait for the new
record girl congrats thank you so much
[Music]
you